What's up? I'm streaming. By the way, >> this is Did Did
you see what happened? >> Yeah, I think so. >> Yeah.
Like, dude, Charlie's going to be
>> I'm pretty sure he's already dead. Yeah, >> dude.
We're We are We are We are So, >> by we, I mean we as a
country right now, the United States in the current >> Dude,
I will give it I will give it to Destiny in a crisis situation.
He like saved her completely here. Like, if she wasn't,
he saved her totally. >> Like, yeah. like that the party,
but like mostly like
>> I think that it's so funny that she like he totally
fixed it. He like that was actually smooth. That was actually
smooth the way he did that cuz he could tell where she was going
and he cut her off and she's like yeah like yeah America's like
the parties but most of all it's us man we're throwing a disconnect.
It is fixed. It's fixed by not existing. Okay, guys. Oh my god.
Charlie Kirk shot actually like horrifically. Like I I watched
his footage, man, and it was
it was like brutal. And I just knew right away. I knew immediately
that like there's no way he survives through that. Like, right,
he's um
like it was I don't even I don't even know how to dramatize it
effectively without feeling like uh sick about it. Was it several
times? I don't believe so. Yeah, Kerski, that's what I'm saying,
too. Um, some people are saying you get hydrostatic shock on
the exit wound, right? Like you get an expanding exit wound for
shots like that and there's a decent chance that like um he had
like spinal cord damage and [__] like right when
it happened. Yeah, he was like gone like gone immediately.
Yeah, there's a
fountain of blood. Like even Yeah, even if you'd had a surgeon
there, like once you've destroyed like that side of the karate
so completely, I don't know what happens, man. Horrifying stuff.
I can't imagine. Okay.
God, I I'm gonna have a hard time because I feel like probably
what I'm going to do most of the stream is just watch other people's
reactions and kind of process them. Uh, someone linked me an
aerodyite reel. She just shows the full thing like uncensored.
It's from a further away angle so you don't see like the blood
spray like the closer angle, but I was just like, bro, really?
You're going to going to put an Instagram reel with that uncensored
like the second literally he's not even cold in the ground yet?
That's crazy. Uh, if it's a groper, would Nick boast about his
this dude's abilities? No, I don't think so. Well, apparently
his family was right there.
Those graphic videos on the front page Drudge Report. I saw the
most graphic video. It's uh reallyed up. You look at the bottom
of the closest video to him, you see it says 2 26 out of 259.
So, there's a longer close-up video that hasn't been seen yet.
Yeah, but like he's out of frame almost immediately and people
are probably rushing around. And you think it was a Groper Hyoko?
I don't know. I don't know if there's like a lot of purpose in
speculating on it yet. speculating on who it might be, why they
did it. I I feel like we don't know anything. Although, I am
just now
that uh the been apprehended.
So, they got the at least, right? Yeah. Yeah, I know what you
mean.
Uh the person who linked it to me, and I don't I don't fault
them for this. They didn't say not save for life when they first
linked it to me. To be real, I opened that in a grocery store.
Okay.
Uh with not with not with the sound, but just like
dude uh
it was brutal. It was brutal.
You condemn your Discord going full Boston bomber earlier today
and immediately trying to spread info of the first incorrect
suspect. No, it's a Discord. That's what they're going to do.
I mean, you could sit there and be an intelligent person and
say you guys are like way too you're going way too ham on this.
You're like trying to figure out who this person like, you could
say that, but people are still going to do it. I don't see any
reason. Like I I'll just say it's dumb to like immediately try
to figure out who like it's the guy who gets dragged out, right?
There's a guy who gets dragged out right afterwards and people
like, "Oh, that's the but nobody knew it was the Nobody knew
that for sure. It was just speculation."
It was just speculation. I saw the video that that dude had to
be in the military. Uh there is a video of the guy on a rooftop
and he is like he's there in like all black. You can barely see
them on the rooftop. And then yeah, it's a very accurate shot
at a pretty long distance. So, it's like a rifle. Uh I I'm pretty
sure it's it's going to be a class of rifle very likely that
would never be controlled by any gun restrictions. So everybody
who's trying to make this about 2A, everybody's trying to go,
"Oh, well guys, if we just been allowed to restrict 2A, this
wouldn't have happened or some like that's so it's going to be
a gun that has nothing to do like it's going to be it's going
to be some rifle that you could take hunting." I I believe, but
that's that's like my opinion. Uh could be totally wrong. We
we technically don't know. Wasn't a gunfree zone anyway. I don't
believe so. I think I think you actually had the right to carry
on that campus, which people are going to say is like removed
as well. confirmed it was not the old guy. Yeah, confirmed it
was not the old guy. Tis not the old guy. All right. I was thinking
about opening up some of the like one of the news networks and
just like drifting on that for a little bit, but I think we've
gotten like a lot of the coverage out already.
We got here a little too late to drift off of the news networks.
You know what I'm saying? We got here a little too late. Let
me go over to MSNBC.
MSNBC was live earlier. Do they not have their [__]
live? Hello. Hello. Hello. Oh, I guess not. Uh, live news. Dude,
YouTube sucks so badly at finding live channels sometimes.
CBS, I guess. >> Again, uh quite a few updates coming from
that press conference from those federal, state, and local leaders
and officials with a person of interest in custody. Where does
the investigation go from here? And I know it's in early days,
but uh it's all boots on the ground right now. >> That's
right. Well, they're still analyzing surveillance video. They
want to match this individual with um everything So, it looks
like uh it looks like they got the guy. I believe Cash Mattel
just tweeted out that they got the guy. >> So, that's happening
right now. They're also uh likely interviewing this individual.
Then from there, they >> So, real quick, uh the subject
for the horrific today that took the life of Charlie Kirk is
now in custody. Thank you to local and state authorities in Utah
for your partnership with FBI. We will provide updates when available.
Cash tweeted at 3 p.m. that they got the Well, he tweeted 20
minutes ago that they got the right guy. So, I'm I'm guessing
this is it, right? Anyway, >> they want to get associates
uh close pull all of that in, review all of that. So, the clock
starts ticking now on that part of the investigation.
While they're doing that, they're building a
this individual did leading up to the moment of pulling that
trigger. And and I know we're looking >> is broken. Oh,
you see Reddit. Oh, >> what happened this afternoon? That
stood out to both of you that press conference is hearing officers
from the university campus police were actually on the ground
out there. Uh he was saying six officers, possibly more that
were uh also in planes close.
Officers were also there. But when you hear that some 3,000 people
were in attendance, what goes in in your head then? >> Okay,
hold on. I'm going to set up blastoff tweet and stuff as well.
>> Wide open. Uh, no cover, no checkpoints, no metal detectors.
Um, already just the fact that they held >> really gonna
critique Charlie Kirk's opac opsec right now. That seems kind
of [__] up, guys. Okay, hold on. There's a blastoff
tweet in the kick chat, guys. Like the blastoff tweet. Engage
with the blastoff tweet. Let me throw it over in the Twitch chat
for everybody.
Guys, we're live on Twitch today as well.
All right, twitch.tv/jstlk.
Hop in over there. Yeah. Okay. Okay. So, I'm just making sure
some stuff's going on here.
There we go. All right. All >> Law enforcement is at a
disadvantage to keep it safe, but there are things that they
could have. >> Maybe don't talk to today. He's full black
pill right now. >> You you heard the police earlier acknowledge
that, you know, they might have been able to prevent this, but
to have somebody on a roof in an open air, >> dude, they're
just going to show this whole thing or maybe not. that had they
had this is the angle
maybe somebody would have seen >> Charlie Kirk is a martyr
now rip brother that's that's the sad thing is like even if you
don't actually like Charlie Kirk even if you hated everything
he stood
honestly I don't understand how you could be like happy or okay
with this right like it is just the guy's just being martyed
like that is I don't think martyrs can exist today you're wrong
you're absolutely wrong completely wrong
said he was in the middle of answering a question about mash
something and apprehended that person before they took that shot.
>> And we're already hearing about events being postponed,
cancelled, political ones because of what happened with security
plans perhaps being re-examined. Uh do you think that other colleges
or other venues could change the way they approach security given
what happened here today? >> Absolutely. At least in the
short >> Oh, he's answering a question about
wide to campus law enforcement
uh regionally uh and wider across the country. Everybody's going
to be on high alert given that already law enforcement in the
big cities were on high alert because tomorrow is September 11th.
We are in a heightened threat environment. But looking out and
finding that lone wolf before they attack, that is the hardest
thing for law enforcement to do. Everybody's going to be >> No,
Zezy. No, this isn't true. >> Essentially, um that >> uh
Crassenstein tweet. Okay, hold on. We're going to be going through
uh watch the Jesse Waters clip. Hold on. We'll watch the scene
clip first. We'll watch whatever this is and then uh Jesse Waters.
Apparently Jesse Waters saying some goofy stuff.
Oh yeah, this is the this is the kind of that I'm quite scared
of. Okay, wait, hold on. There's no way.
There's no way. >> Do you know how many transgender Americ
was like holy that was playing muted and I was like no way that
I just played it.
So interesting.
Okay, we've not found the suspect. This is not funny. Today is
the day to try something new. Paddington, the official Paddington
Bear account with 400,000 followers.
Okay. Okay, dude. First the trans people, then the furries. It's
It's insane stuff, guys. It's wild stuff.
Okay. I'm going to watch I'll watch the Jesse Waters thing in
just a second. But what was I going to pull? I was going to pull
something with this. Oh, I saw Masterson. Apparently Mastersonson
feels like he's got the guy. Speaking of engaging in like hunting
these guys down. Amazing. Claw Shark seconds. CL Cloud Shark.
Clout Shark. Uh I don't know what that is, but I saw post this.
Uh Charlie Kirk is coming to my college tomorrow. I really hope
someone evaporates him. Literally. Let's just say something big
will happen tomorrow. It's like this guy, this person. I Dude,
I don't know. I think this is uh way too You're You're jumping
ahead way too far. Okay. I don't know, man.
I Yeah, I I think it's from two. I know. Is that a trans woman?
It seems to be. Oh god, a M Americ. Uh-oh. Maybe Charlie Kirk
shouldn't have spent years being a hateful demagogic fascist
and this wouldn't have happened. Maybe he should take some personal
responsibility. I mean, he's dead.
He is dead.
I don't
dude. Some of these people
is so well is also a sociopath, but this is also tweet. I don't
know. I don't know why people do this. This tweet's gonna get
blown up. This tweet is already massive. 12 million views already.
Yeah, these people, I do not care. They've grifted tirelessly
for years to tear this country apart, make everything worse,
and put us all in danger. Charlie Cook wouldn't pick on you to
put you out if you were on fire. An evil man who sold his humanity
a long time ago. I will not. Oh, sorry. This is disgusting. You
can still delete it. I will not. You're all a bunch of weak,
unamerican traders. He We used to be a country that knew how
to handle fascists. All of you would be [__] goostepping
in World War II.
Uh, Charlie Kirk, it's worth to it's worth to have a cost of
unfortunately some gun deaths every single year so that we can
have the Second Amendment. Yeah, I'm sorry. If you if you put
this clip in front of Charlie Kirk where he's like, "Yes, we
have to accept some bad things happen with sec with the Second
Amendment," he would still stand behind the Second Amendment.
You understand that, right? You all get it, right? That he would
definitely have done like he would he would have said, "No, no,
no. That's acceptable and that sucks, right? That's the whole
point of saying this is that one death shouldn't change your
mind. Calling someone unamerican after saying how great it is
that someone got assassinated
that they always play word games with this stuff too. It's like
America would go, "Well, I'm not celebrating. I'm just saying
I don't care." And it's like, dude, okay. One guy, member of
the crowd at the event seconds after when everybody running away
films himself and plugs his ticket and Instagram start. Oh, I
I'm okay, Matt Slice. I don't care about some random doing that,
but thank you for the link. I just it's like dude who I why would
I I think that's like gross. Why would I then go and put more
on there? Or why would I like amplify that, right? Just weird.
Just weird. That's all. Yeah. Yeah. I've seen this. We were just
watching this clip. We're just watching this clip through or
sorry, this clip is the same one Merrick has here. Everyone is
trying to get us to performatively act like we care. It's gross.
I see why Merrick is angry. You don't have to care. You could
You know what you can do, Private Huff? If you have bad things
to say, this is something we teach like 10-year-olds and then
we try to make it like a parable they live by. If you don't have
anything nice to say, then shut the up. If you don't have anything
nice to say, don't say anything at all. Guess what? You can just
shut the [__] up.
It's so easy to just shut the [__] up. You don't
have to go online and go, "Oh, it's a terrible tragedy that Charlie
Kirk got." You could just Sorry, you're saying that people are
telling you you have to feel bad. You don't have to feel bad.
But if all you want to do on the day that this guy gets shot
in the throat and dies in front of his family, if all you want
to do is go, "Yeah, he deserved that." Or, "Yeah, I don't care."
Then why not just keep that to yourself? Why Why make like terrible
uh why make like
why make your divisive rhetoric like uh a thing? Why put it out
there? Even you don't have to, by the way. I'm just telling you
that nobody if you're arguing that people are telling you you
have to feel good about it or you have to feel a certain way
not good that you have to feel like sad or sorrowful. I would
just say no. You could also just ignore the internet for a day.
Pretty easy. Pretty easy, dude. Where? Who's making these? Who's
making these? That's terrible. Okay, that's terrible. That's
terrible.
That's terrible. I don't know who's making these. Oh, that's
my docket. Get out of there. Well, that's something else. What
will happen to the tour? What will happen to the tour, guys?
What'll happen to the tour?
So,
uh, all his just continuing on with the Meric tweets here. All
the sickopantic little fans should stand by y'all's principles.
This is what the world y'all wanted. Y'all started everything
and now you want to cry. All of you are weak. Um, I I find it
so weird that there are people who are like, "Oh, you wanted
you wanted to be fascist. You wanted to pretend to be fascist.
Now someone now one of your guys gets shot and you guys want
to put the guns away." It's like, "No, no, no, no. They don't
want to put the guns away. Actually, they don't want to do that.
Anyway, it's just it's silly. It's all It's all goofy. I got
a whole bunch of reactions. I've got
Man, hold on one second. Okay. Is there being a single right-winger
in response to this going pro gun control?
Oh, yeah. I don't I don't think there will be. Like, this is
Yeah, it's stupid to talk about that. The Z clip is a banger.
Dude, I I was just Listen, that got sent to me and I was like,
"Bro, there's no way." Like,
it's so unfathomable. It's so stupid.
I don't know why you would I don't know why you would do that.
You guys missed it. Okay. See,
Z went over to uh Z went over to Destiny's stream right after
this happened. I don't understand why. Like, I don't understand
why she did this, but hold on. Yeah, we'll show the clip. Just
give me a second. Turn it up. Well, ho, what's >> Whoa,
whoa, whoa. Little loud. Little >> Well, ho, what's up?
I'm streaming, by the way. >> This is Did Did you see what
happened? >> Yeah, I think so. >> Yeah. Like, dude,
Charlie's going to be
>> I'm pretty sure he's already dead. Yeah, >> dude.
We're We are We are We are So, >> by we, I mean we as a
country right now, the United States, and the current >> Dude,
I will give it I will give it to Destiny in a crisis situation.
He like saved her completely here. Like if she wasn't,
he saved her totally. He's like, "Yeah, this is what you mean.
Yeah, this is what you mean right now." He like totally he picked
it up. He saw what she was saying and he like totally fixed it,
but she like didn't she didn't get it at >> Like like Yeah,
like that the party, but like mostly like >> I think that
it's so funny that she like he totally fixed it. He like that
was actually smooth. That was actually smooth the way he did
that because he could tell where she was going and he cut her
off and she's like, "Yeah, like yeah, America's and like the
party's but most of all it's us, man. We're fuck." And he disconnects
like like Yeah, like that the party, but like mostly like
>> I think that the I think that we're super [__]
I agree. Hold on. Wait. I'll I'll text you on Discord.
I I don't want to say anything crazy that's going to ruin her.
On both Z's website and Reddit account, her organization stated,
>> "Oh, did I did I include that? I didn't I didn't even
see this." >> Goals were taking the fight directly to Charlie
Kirk by following him around on college campuses. >> Well,
how what's up? >> That's uh
I I thought I didn't have the AI bit at the end. I guess I did.
Whoops.
That Well, hold on. There was an two things got sent to me. I
thought I downloaded the nonAI bit one. That's a little funny.
anyway, website was 404. Yeah, the website got taken down. The
website did get taken down. That's funny. Yeah, this is the thing.
Latigious Gamer is I I don't know why she would come on to talk
to him directly about this. That's just goofy, right? Isn't that
goofy?
Like, why would you go and talk about this the within minutes?
I want to say this is within an hour of Charlie Kirk getting
shot. Yeah, it it's it's just wild to me. Holy. I must have gotten
retweeted or quote tweeted by somebody big. I've got 43 comments
here and 100 likes. I just I know my stuff will get uh swarmed
by certain people. Okay, this is very funny. 43 comments, 108
likes. Wow. Wait, there's also a dicker tweet that goes along
with this. Hold on. I should probably go to the air one. Give
me a second. Where's the Where's the Aerodite tweet with the
dicker's response? Hold on. Give me a second cuz this is just
This is very funny. Okay.
Oh, hold on. Oh, did he reply with it? No, he quote tweeted it.
Okay. Okay. Okay. This is uh this is it right here. So, Erdite
quote tweets this guy. The left is literally celebrating that
Charlie Kirk was shot in the neck. This is who they are. Never
forget. Never forgive. No. Do not let Charlie's death be weaponized
by people who won't stand for free speech. I am the left. Okay.
Canadian participating in American politics. Uh thousands of
likes as a liberal condemning the violence and praying for Charlie.
The left has ubiquitously responded with a condemnation of of
the violence and uh dictors just okay. Unless you're destiny,
you you respond with a condemnation of the condemnations. >> Anybody
on the left that does any sort of disavow whatever I think is
weak. Yeah. I >> We can't see your Twitter. Oh, did she
break? Wait, what is happening?
Why did this happen? What the [__] What the [__]
Hold on. It's fixed now. It'll never happen again. It'll never
happen again. No, no, no, no, no. Sorry. There there going to
be little hiccups like that, guys, cuz I had to My OBS is like
kind of [__] Anyway,
>> I was reading Erdite's tweet. Okay, we go over to this
>> on the left that does any sort of disavow whatever I
think is weak. I I saw Nome doing it earlier. Anybody on the
left that does any sort of disavow whatever I think is weak.
Yeah, I saw Newsome doing it earlier.
Wow. You're posted on r/ Destiny now. Oh, that's where it's coming
from.
That's very funny. Sir, sir, are you trying to say that they
got Charlie? Are you trying to say that right now? Bloody bastard.
I get into British after the SARS. Okay. Coordinating to pin
the blame on Z, Destiny, and America. What do you mean coord?
a while. Actually, by the way, all I say
all I say is what my tweet says. I didn't know the AI bit was
there, which does do that a little bit. Okay, but um my tweet's
very my condemnation is all here. Okay, it's in the tweet. Oh,
whoops. I God damn it. I just think I think it's actually ghoullish
in my opinion to hop on a stream immediately,
right? to immediately hop on a stream and go, "Dude, we're
like, maybe wait until you're offline. Maybe wait until you're
offline or maybe maybe maybe obligatory night kitten tweet, I
guess." So, even after one of his political targets gets assassinated,
he still can't say he condemns political
Yeah,
I know. I know. That's crazy.
Anyway, I thought the the dicker's response to was pretty funny.
the the
max the the federal video. Okay, I get I get why Dickers didn't
want to quote tweet that, you know,
hold on. Where's uh where's Dickers here? I understand there's
some some concern about quote tweeting that sometimes, but this
is from Max. This is from Federal R. Okay. Yeah, it doesn't look
quite as good quote tweeting this account. I know. I get it.
I get it. Bad things seem to happen anytime Dickers quote tweets.
No. No.
Come on. All right. We're still We're still going through all
of the reactions to this, guys. We're going through a bunch of
the
God. Uh I don't know if I need to go to the governor's press
conference. I thought it was a little weird that um that Donald
Trump like so clearly Okay,
The internet's like now. I hate the internet so much. Okay, Donald
Trump was the one who announced this. Everybody else I feel like
they probably told him like, "Hey, don't like announce it, but
like he is dead." just so you know cuz a bunch of people were
like trying to keep saying like he was alive probably until you
know close family was notified and stuff right like you don't
you don't announce a death before the family's notified or at
least it's like a faux paw to do so but then Trump just comes
out and he's just like you know what thoughts and prayers to
Charlie Kirk and his family Trump wanted the scoop I just thought
it was funny like a little little funny light-hearted thing throughout
all of this
uh this was a video that got posted I believe this is real okay
this is on this is on the top of the lossy center, which is where
they said the gunman was. >> Get right up, >> There's
just some dude who's out here and he's like filming. He's like,
"Why is there a guy on the roof?"
>> So, there's somebody on the roof over
>> Just saying. Huh? >> He just ran from uh
over Where's my finger? Well, from over there. Ran in.
And now he's right there.
Just saying. Justing right up. >> Just saying. Just saying.
Oh, hold on. Additional footage shows an individual running across
the roof of the lossi center in the moments after the
hold on spin.
Oh, there he is.
>> Bro, that's crazy. That's crazy that people source this
stuff, right? And you see this guy like you literally see him
running across the rooftop over there like running away after
a shot. That's an that is where everybody's basically confirmed
that that's the guy. I believe the the cops and uh the governor
confirmed that that was the guy on top of the lossi center. MSD
just pulled up your tweet. Direct hit. Oh well, unlucky. Yeah,
that's crazy.
Rough view to the stage. So, this is from the This is like zoomed
in a little bit to be like from the roof and then I guess this
is like probably down where the stage was.
So, he's up on this roof. Says this roughly correlates to known
public statements by officials. A spokeswoman for the Utah Valley
University, Ellen Trainor, said that Kirk was struck by a suspect
who had fired from the Losi Center, a building about 200 yards
away. So lossy center and then this was Yeah, that was the